und es geht um unseren beiden
Lieblingsfreund Karl Lauterbach meine
These heute Abend ist nämlich das Karl
Lauterbach sollte Karl leiserbach werden
und wie komme ich darauf
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach ist ja eine der Stimmen der
Regierung die auch nach zweieinhalb
Jahren corona-pandemie und nach all den
neuen Erkenntnissen immer noch nach
harten Maßnahmen rufen was heißt eine
der Stimmen eigentlich versteht sich
niemand so sehr auf die Panik mache wie
er keiner kann es so gut und vor knapp
zwei Stunden habe ich mich bei Twitter
über ihn aufgeregt da hat er nämlich
getwittert Zitat in USA ist eine neue
Variante aufgetreten die deutlich
anstecken als omicom ba2 zu sein scheint
niemand hört das gerne aber es ist so
das Coronavirus bleibt unberechenbar mal
wieder eine Warnung nachdem Lauterbach
SV wenigen Tagen prognostizierte dass
wir im Herbst eine kindervariante
kriegen könnten aufgrund seiner
evidenzfreien Warnung warf ihm dann
nicht nur Virologen wie Jonas Schmidt
schon er sieht und Hendrik
strickpanikmache vor was wir in
Deutschland brauchen ist Schluss mit der
Panikmache schluss mit den lauten Tönen
und deswegen mein Wunsch Karl Lauterbach
soll endlich Karl leiserbach werden
Nina dein Wunsch ist mein Wunsch und ihr
seid heute tatsächlich und gemeint
wirklich nur nur zustimmen denn was Karl
Lauterbach der am Sonntag im Bild am
Sonntag immerhin also
abgeliefert hat das war glaube ich etwas
wo er mit einer Schlagzeile gerechnet
hat es wurde zwar eine andere dann aber
ich glaube er ist einfach so
medienversessen dass er glaubt ich muss
sie was bieten deswegen rede ich mal von
der killervariante das funktioniert bei
Bild bitte am Sonntag sehr gut und dann
haben die die Schlagzeile und ich bin
wieder da auf den Titel Seiten und
kommen in die nächste Runde der
Talkshows wo ich ja immer unbedingt hin
will ich hätte mir nicht gedacht dass es
so platt ist ich bin mittlerweile davon
überzeugt ich finde nur mittlerweile
müsste er doch den Schuss gehört haben
es müssen auch vernünftige Leute geben
eine Bundesregierung bei ihm auch im
Ministerium er hatte einen guten
kommunikations-profi hier dem sagt pass
mal aufgehalten bisschen weniger
Talkshow bisschen mehr Ministerium da
gibt es ja viel zu tun so kann man das
haben wir doch in der corona-pandemie
gesehen
Digitalisierung kommt nicht voran die
die Gehälter für die Pflegekräfte ist
vielen Pflegekräfte es gibt so viel zu
tun in diesem Haus ich mir wünsche dass
ihr ein Teil der Zeit den er aufwendet
in Talkshows Panik zu verbreiten
aufwendig für die Zeit in seinem Haus
das ist weniger ist da gibt's auch
weniger Schlagzeilen aber das hilft
vielleicht die Bevölkerung und auch den
Pflegekräften mehr als nur Panik zu
verbreiten und die Menschen im gleichen
also nenne ihn seit er von dem
killer-virus gesprochen hat für mich nur
noch killerkabel das muss ich sagen weil
das ist war so daneben das ist eines
Ministers vollkommen unwürdig ein
Minister muss eine Art von common sense
herstellen wollen dass er ein Land auch
psychologisch interpretiert dass er es
an die Hand nimmt dass er es in die
richtige Richtung führt aber nicht
laufend erschreckt und in Panik versetzt
und jetzt sind die Leute gerade ein
bisschen freigelassen worden sie müssen
keine Maske mehr tragen überall und der
kommt Karl Lauterbach um die Ecke wie
kann denn
der Minister der diesen Lockerungen
keine maskenpflicht mehr zugestimmt hat
gleich im gleichen Atemzug sagen aber im
Herbst wird es wieder ganz fürchterlich
entweder oder dann muss er sich doch
entscheiden ich bin gegen die Lockerung
der maskenpflicht gegen die Aufgabe
dagegen setzt es aber nicht durch dann
muss er dafür antreten dann muss man
sagen ich stimme dem Gesetzentwurf des
FDP Justizministers nicht zu aus diesem
Grund weil im Herbst kommt ein ganz
schrecklicher Virus aber nicht dem
zustimmen und dann hinterher damit er
wieder mal
Bela du hast gesagt er hat den Schuss
nicht gehört er schießt ja laufend
selbst
er will auf sich aufmerksam machen und
das war wieder mal so ein Zitat von dem
man genau wusste was es auslöst und das
ist unverantwortlich ehrlich gesagt so
ein Minister ist nicht mehr tragbar aber
wie oft haben wir das schon gesagt er
macht sie immer wieder aber
unverantwortlich ist ja aus meiner Sicht
auch dass er ja auch dem Anliegen ein
Bärendienst erweist weil erstens will
keiner mehr hören zweitens genau das
also heute maskenpflichtweg morgen kommt
die killervariante die Leute denken
habt ihr so noch alle in der
Bundesregierung von daher weißt dem ein
Bärendienst das wahrscheinlich die
Menschen auch nicht mehr ernst nehmen
werden und mir kommt es so ein bisschen
vor wie so ein ADHS-Kind was immer dann
wenn es mal keine Aufmerksamkeit macht
dann irgendwas macht wie es gar nicht
wie Mutter wieder rennt wie man den
Eindruck den man hat ausdrücken soll
ohne dass es justiziabel wird also ich
sage man die vorsichts der Form die ich
finden kann der hat nicht mehr alle am
streuschen dann kommt es in der
Situation mit der killervariante zu
kommen zeugt nicht von
diesen es gab doch den den den
griechischen Finanzminister der uns alle
in Aufruf versetzt genau so kommt mir
das vor dass er für diese Zeit so
eingesetzt wird und irgendwann ist die
kahlzeit vorbei wenn er so weitermacht
glaube ich früher als später wer soll
denn dann eine ganz schicke Frau und er
muss Motorrad
was sagen Sie also ich finde das der
gesamte spd-teil der Bundesregierung
keine gute Figuration
ja und der kann bisher noch nicht so
viel vor der konnte ja der konnte jetzt
6 % Rentenerhöhung konnte er verkünden
konnte aber eigentlich nichts dafür
da glaube ich einfach Profi ist er da
Profi Profi genug die der restliche
spd-teil ist tatsächlich ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen zum Weglaufen gleichwohl
ist es so muss man realistisch sehen wir
sind derzeit in Kriegszeiten da können
jetzt auch nicht alle paar Wochen
irgendwelche Minister zurücktreten und
dann neue reinkommen wenn dann müsste es
Regierung das Lambrecht zurücktreten
soll bitte sie haben doch gesagt dass
Lamprecht zu ich habe nicht gesagt das
Lamprecht zurücktreten soll sondern das
völlig deplatziert ist und ich fand Frau
Lamprecht von Anfang an als Ministerin
da nicht wirklich an geeigneter Position
gestellt ich kenne sie noch als
Staatssekretär im Finanzministerium da
war es ehrlich gesagt ähnlichem bedeutet
ähnlich können Sie eine Anekdote mit uns
teilen über voller Brecht im
Finanzausschuss das sind ja nicht
öffentliche Sitzungen aber wenn sie sich
sozusagen entlang hangeln müssen an
ihrem Sprechzettel dann wird es halt
immer schon schwierig und man erkennt
das weiß der Kommunikationsprofi
wenn dann jemand tatsächlich nicht so
viel Ahnung von der Materie hat oder
wenn jemand das sozusagen nur als
Gedächtnisstütze nimmt ich stimme ihrem
Eindruck zu der SPD Teil des Kabinetts
ist erbärmlich die Grünen machen die
beste Figur die FDP macht eine ganz gute
Figur Frau stark Zimmermann ist
diejenige die sozusagen
da die die klarste Figur ist im Bereich
von Verteidigung wo du keine kriegen das
ich rede jetzt vom Ukraine krieg ich
meine
zulässig dass Leute anderer Meinung sind
als ich das halte ich für zulässig ja
und insofern für mich ist im Moment die
entscheidende Frage der Ukraine kriegt
da ist Frau stark Zimmermann schon die
richtige ich wollte aber eigentlich
sagen dass diese Regierung es an den
schon an den Sollbruchstellen angekommen
also eine Koalition zwischen dieser SPD
und den beiden anderen Parteien wird
immer finde ich immer fragiler und ich
vermisse aber eine nach vorne drängende
Union die dann sagt mit denen geht's
nicht mehr wir leben ja nicht in
einfachen Zeiten
nutzen das machen mein Eindruck ist dass
Herr Merz auch kein Wert darauf legt in
dieser Situation mit diesem Krieg
Kanzler zu werden also ein bisschen
leise-treterisch kommt mir die Union
schon vor woran liegt das ich habe
ehrlich gesagt im gänzlich anderen
Eindruck wenn Sie sich anschauen wie wie
im Bundestag diskutiert wird wo auch
Friedrich Merzig Punkte macht wir haben
vorhin über die 100 Milliarden
gesprochen Sondervermögen wo wir ganz
klar unsere Punkte gemacht haben in
denen wir auch gesagt haben das sind die
Sekretären warum wir dann von denen wir
abhängig machen dass wir dann auch
zustimmen und am Schluss ist die CDU
Deutschlands eine Partei die immer auch
regieren will und deren
Selbstverständnis ist auch ist zu
regieren und von daher sollte es dazu
einem koalitionsprogramm stehen wenn
natürlich stehen wir natürlich bereit
als Union die corona-pandemie
aufarbeitet und auch ihre getroffenen
Entscheidungen gegenüber den Menschen
also ich glaube da ist jetzt derzeit
jetzt nicht unbedingt die Zeit einer
Selbstbeschäftigung in einer
onkette-kommission die am Schluss
vielleicht sowieso nichts zu entscheiden
hat ich finde dass wir wenn wir einen
Strich drunter machen in den letzten
zwei Jahren gut durch diese corona-krise
durchgekommen sind sowohl wirtschaftlich
aber auch bei den krankheits- und
Todesfällen es hat vieles aufgedeckt was
wir noch verbessern müssen insbesondere
im Gesundheitsbereich aber ich habe das
schon mal vor zwei Wochen hier an der
Stelle gesagt wenn ich die vier Monate
von Carl Lauterbach Vergleiche mit den
zwei Jahren zwei Jahren von Jens Spahn
hat Sie Jens Spahn eigentlich ziemlich
gut gemacht aber
ich finde immer noch mal rein sonst hier
zu wenig Sendezeit hier übrig gelassen
die letzte Frage die ich nämlich noch
habe zu meiner These und Karl Lauterbach
gibt es denn
irgendeine Chance dass er zurücktreten
muss überhaupt also wenn er sich so
weiter fällt und mich jeden Tag
wahnsinnig macht auf Twitter wegen der
neuen Variante ist ja kein Grund warum
man zurücktreten muss auch wenn die
Bürger sich wünschen
nein so nicht aber natürlich wenn er
völlig das Vertrauen der Ministerin
Minister des Bundeskanzlers verliert
wenn er die Bevölkerung in Erregung
versetzt ohne Lösungen zu bieten wenn
der tatsächlich
weiterhin übersteigert in Talkshows
drängt ohne die Arbeit im Ministerium zu
machen wenn er nachweisen kann dass da
wichtige Arbeiten liegen bleiben dann
kommt schon so ein Moment wo ein
Bundeskanzler sich die Frage stellt
nützt er mir noch oder schadet er mir
und der Punkt ist noch nicht erreicht
aber wir werden irgendwann da Einkommen
und dann wird man sehen ob Karl
Lauterbach lernt oder ob er weiterhin in
die Tokyos drängt der lernt nicht ich
glaube das ist in diesem Fall haben wir
es mit dem typischen Kartenhaus Fall zu
tun wenn du eine Karte rausziehst bricht
alles zusammen wenn man Karl Lauterbach
zurückziehen würde als Bundeskanzler
stellt sich doch sofort die Frage warum
ist eigentlich Frau Lambrecht noch
Ministerin und andere auch
Gesundheitsminister als Gesundheit
ich wollte sagen wenn der Bundeskanzler
ihn zurückzieht stellt sich sofort die
Frage warum ist Frau Lamprecht noch
Ministerin wenn du einen gehen lässt
müssen andere mitgehen und dann hast du
vielleicht eine richtige fette Regierung
deshalb bleibt da auch noch eine Spiegel
ist doch in Urlaub gefahren dann ist sie
gegangen aber Frau Lamprecht nach dem
Auftritt ging es nicht anders ist ja
auch selber zurückgetreten ja von ihrer
Partei zurückgetreten worden sagen wir
mal so aber die SPD tritt doch niemanden
zurück wenn dann müssten sie alle
zurücktreten fast außer Hubertus Heil
außer Hubertus halt der Meinung bin ich
auch alle zurücktreten geht ja nicht im
Kabinett Uli das heißt als letzte Frage
wem würdest du denn als erstes schmeißen
wenn du jetzt heute könntest ja ich
meine wir reden über Lambrecht wir reden
über Lauterbach Lauterbach ist ja Moment
abgesehen von seiner Rhetorik nicht mehr
gefragt weil die weil die Leute sind ja
relativ entspannt die gehen in die
Urlaubszeit gefragt ist jetzt ein eine
effiziente Besetzung des
Verteidigungsministeriums ob das Mann
oder Frau ist interessiert mich nicht
Frau stark Zimmermann werden es sehr
vorrangig wie nur glaube ich aber
vielleicht findet sie auch jemand anders
da müsste
an denen
geht er dann zum Friseur ich weiß es